[Music]
hey good morning and good afternoon
party people we are here to do the
honest trailer commentary for
john wiki wiki john john wick uh
chapters two
and three yeah not sorry uh
i'm here with danielle uh we're gonna be
talking about
our real deep behind-the-scenes thought
process for john wick two and three
uh we're also gonna be showing you some
cut scenes we will be responding to
comments and questions from viewers like
yourself so keep them coming in the chat
and we will tease you with next week's
honest trailer at the very end so stick
around for that
uh but right up top let's just get right
into it because these movies sure don't
waste any time
um what do you feel about the john wick
sequels um i will start i like them
they're fine um i mean they're really
good uh i i still think the first one is
the best one but i think that these are
uh uh passable if not really excellent
sequels they they fall into the more is
better trap where i think that
there was a certain purity to the first
one of they killed his dog so he's gonna
kill
all of them and they try to in two and
three lionsgate rightfully he's like
we've got a hit on our hands let's make
it into a world and keep building it out
and giving you more and more layers of
how the assassin bureaucracy works that
i don't need uh i just wish he got a
series of house pets that were killed
and he just kept avenging them
that's all i wanted but uh that's my uh
in a nutshell take on the john wick
sequels what say ye
um yeah i really like them they're
really fun like for me this i i
i was going to say this and i'm
realizing how weird this is going to
make me sound they're really good date
movies
um because you could just like yeah you
could just like hang out and like watch
all the
all the the headshots and people getting
killed with books and other different
kinds of peripheral items
um and it's just like it's really fun
and it's kind of brainless and you can
like crack jokes and do all that stuff
so
um plus it's uh this is gonna sound
weird for someone who uh
classically like everyone knows i love
wrestling um
sometimes with action scenes i can it
starts to be too much and i just tune
out
and just like with the first one i do
think that they do a really good job of
like
telling a story with the action where it
isn't just
i mean we do all the head shots and all
that stuff but there is a story for
everything that there's a library story
there's you know there's the hall of
mirror story
and it keeps it really interesting and
lively for me so yeah good date movie uh
find someone you want to make out with
and do it to john wick
well you're gonna have a lot of
proposals in the in the comments
uh lon what's your take uh i i love i
mean to me there's like there's the
three
you know there's the trinity of modern
action franchises which is
wix fast and or furious
and you're you're mission impossible tom
cruise
being a superhero like like those are my
favorites and yeah i really like how
they approach this one which is the
first movie gives you
all you need to know about john wick the
man like
we're never going to explore his
character in any greater depth
it's done he's that's who he is he's you
know we we found out his name is jagdani
in part three that's the only new
wrinkle um
and i'm i'm like roughly okay with that
like we know who wick is he's
established and now we're just yeah
we're making this
ridiculous totally goofy and cartoonish
but i still love it
like assassin verse and and now we just
get to explore peel back all of those
various
crazy layers and it gets more you know
like
large scale and silly all the time and
yeah i mean i think
the best movie from this whole trilogy
is two because it takes
it marries the stuff i liked about the
first movie
with this really clever and creative and
also really goofy
larger world of everybody's doing crime
all the time
okay well i think we'll all have more
thoughts on that but let's roll the
honest trailer for
uh wix two and three
i'm a little sorry we didn't do a parody
like wild wild wick
wiki wiki like hip-hop zombies
summarizing the actual
well yeah trilogy there is one outtake
that may reference it
oh okay we'll see
before you see john wick with extremely
sad dad energy
revisit the sequels about a man with
care and hair killing anyone who gets
between him and the manager i seek a
meeting with the one who sits above the
table
john wick two and john wick three
parabellum
huh one of these titles is not like the
others
um i guess a couple things about that
one i have yet to see nobody which i
really
want to do how does it compare have you
so none of us have seen it
okay well it looks like it's good it's
good it feels it's the same
yeah it's good it's exactly that energy
yeah it's exactly what you think it is
yeah um and it's a it's a i would say
it's a budding genre but it's really
like
uh going back to death wish or earlier
where it's like oh you pissed off the
wrong
guy uh which is always that's all you
need as far as an action movie play
i'm concerned he's the wrong guy you you
pissed him off on the wrong day
um but uh yeah
when do we bend it to the breaking point
because i feel like
bob odenkirk sure i like i mean i have
so much residual love for him from mr
show and stuff like that
i think like you get to liam neeson and
like the later
takens like the taken threes of the
world and you're like i mean when they
had to cut
30 times for you to get over the
chain-link fence yeah and yeah i mean
we'll talk about it later but like
keanu's in his 50s i mean he's
he's still he can still do it for sure
but like
are we just tempting fate are we just
gonna get older and more
broke down i mean i don't know to me it
feels like at this point
john wick it's it's like he's basically
he's like a superhero like
it's not believable even if he was like
and like a perfect specimen the stuff
he's doing in these movies is not
realistic or believable
anyway so it's like well if you could
accept a man doing all of these
impossible things
why not accept a man doing all these
impossible things who's also 20 years
past his
like athletic peak like i don't it
really doesn't bother me at all i think
so much of that stuff is the way
that you pull it off technically like it
can look bad to have an older guy try to
do an action scene and you could tell
that they don't
like robert de niro curb stomping the
guy in the irishman where you're like
you could use all the cgi you want i
could tell that is a 75 year old man
moving around
um yeah so i mean you can either
sometimes they can't pull it off but
the john wick movies it's like i can
tell that he's an older guy
looks like there's a little bit of i
feel like we can get
i thought we'd get to later but there's
a bit of a dissonance between
you're right he's a superhero he's
unkillable he can do anything he's
invulnerable but on a scene-by-scene
basis
they play it like he's very human and
hurt and winded and like
oh like he's he's showing damage from uh
all these fights but it never carries
over from scene to scene right
every edit point it gives him like full
health he's back to full health
yeah um so there's a little bit of
dissonance there but uh i just think
it'd be funny is to have
how about academy award winner anthony
hopkins how about uh
he pissed him off um and how about
academy award winner judy dench
yeah you're talking exactly that's a
date movie
yeah honestly
i'm not kidding i would go see judy
dench do a movie like this like why not
like
you got guns she doesn't need to be
punching all the time like
oh um i'm still in under i guess helen
mirren's doing fast and furious yeah
yeah
she's got action scenes in the next one
in the red movies in the red right
that's right yes
it already has kind of crossed over to
old lady action star
all right why not i mean we got the
effect
if we're not going to use the technology
to make it look like 90 year olds are
going on a killing spree
what are we even using the technology
for folks
and i don't want to spoil nobody but if
when we're talking old old person still
got it
action scene uh maybe the best part of
nobody and i'm not talking about bob
odenkirk so that's just
a tease of it some some great some great
old person action we know
it's already been spoiled for me well
but not to me so i'm not gonna
keep that keep down the all right thanks
keep going you remember
john wick one when a gangster killed
john wick's dog so he very
understandably murdered everyone
now in john wick two he'll kill just as
many goons to retrieve his old mustang
that's worth like
50k tops and in john wick three he'll
kill so many people
we're already being taken to cat to task
in the comments by a car aficionado
saying like actually a mint condition
one of those at
auction is much more than 50k i just
looked up the year
of the mustang that it was and looked at
actual prices if you could buy one right
now and it was like 30 to
60k somewhere in there so mint condition
look at it by the time he's done
well by the time he's done with that
it's yeah it's
yeah i feel like uh is it john leguizamo
who plays the the
aurelia yeah yeah um he's definitely
running a scam on john wick because
there's zero
way he could repair that car he could
fix that car
he's definitely buying another one and
then just like pocketing all the gold
coins
or whatever the currency the currency
conversion is
that's no right everybody just kind of
knows what
amount of gold coins everything there's
no
there's no haggling in this world it's
always just
this is worth three gold coins well the
thank you sir three
i did eight just 80 kills is worth 10
coins or whatever yeah it is it an
hourly thing i'd love to see how the
gold coin economy is fine i imagine it
is a bitcoin which is why it's so random
like how it fluctuates so much like a
coin can either get you a new car
or a drink at a bar so it's just like
you check your phone you're like oh i'm
rich or oh i'm poor
like you just have to oh sorry i'm
afraid a coin is worth eight heads this
year
i'm afraid that will be two nfts mr wick
makes more sense than the real thing all
right keep going
for such vague reasons you'll start to
wonder if vengeance fueled murder sprees
aren't just as very specific fetish
i think you're addicted to it to the
vengeance
see mafia guy gets it that dead dog was
just the excuse he was waiting for
sorry i'm thinking of experience
just as kick-ass and monotone as he was
20 years ago
what do you need guns
as he plays the role of john wick well
into his 50s
and somehow gets better at fighting and
shooting along the way
i mean so impressively i guess it makes
sense we'll pause
like uh you know you practice things you
get better at them but i don't know i'm
just not
used to stars doing their own action for
extended long
shots like even marvel movies and stuff
like that it's always
in a dark warehouse and that's not
anthony mackie and like they
and granted they definitely have a stunt
double for this movie for plenty of
shots
yeah well no he well at least for some
of it i think
he was on the horse i read some article
where it said like he learned how to
do trick riding on a horse so i assume
that an amount of that scene was really
him
um more than your average action star
for sure
yeah i think i feel like it was cruz who
introduced this idea of like
what if i just learned how to do all of
this stuff myself
and nobody is doing it on that level
because it's like
part of his religion that he's a
superhero but i think that uh
it definitely has inspired sort of this
new generation
to like take on more of the stuff
themselves and i mean i guess that's
also like the raid
where we're just like kind of melding
like martial arts star and action star
into one seamless yeah but i mean to the
to me it's um i mean
it's no less impressive um but it's just
more novel because
keanu was not always this guy and
they've turned him into this guy
right yeah i know johnny mnemonic he was
like all right i'll be in my trailer you
guys
mess around with whatever enjoy your
laser whip scene yeah
which i still do okay keep going
join this legendary assassin whose name
is still a laxative for criminals
it's not just a car it is john wick's
car
oh but three movies in
he's starting to maybe get a little too
powerful taking out every assassin in
new york
in a row while injured having him
straight up teleport once in a while
i love that and giving him some kind of
immunity to being run over by
cars
yes i just feel like he's got like a
car-shaped callus on the side of his
body
[Music]
this was at the point where i was doing
screenings and junkets because i was
writing for the daily brew in the ucla
paper uh so i went to go see this movie
because i was interviewing brad pitt and
whatever the next day
and no idea what was coming there we
just thought we were watching a movie
and it opens in a very like rom-com kind
of place where he and claire forlani
have this meat cute
on the street and that moment is like he
like they kind of look back like oh they
like each other
and then he gets hit by this card it's
really brutal and crazy and the audience
freaked out like nobody knew it was
coming and people were like screaming
because you know you're not
you just you're not it's not that kind
of energy going into it's
extra bracing and shocking uh so yeah
that's a crazy moment in that
crazy movie well i mean not to call you
out but
at least what you told me was that you
started laughing and nobody else was
of course who wouldn't start laughing at
that and yeah people like kind of looked
at me like i was the college kid
it was like oh immature and it's like
how could you not think that was funny
it's like the most amazing it's like a
fairly brother's shot in the middle of
an otherwise like
a nor ephron movie it's just it's very
jarring it's this wild left turn so yeah
of course i thought it was funny
immediately and assumed other people
would but they and then daniella it
started it started to feel excessive
yeah it started to feel excessive when
you're suggesting we put in the uh
the jamaican accent clip from me joe
black
it's just at
yes uh i wish that we could do unpopular
movies because that's where all the
that's where all the fun stuff is um
but did you just do the martin breast
geely meecho black double
just the yoga scene alone is we'll just
play that unedited
you don't need us to comment on this
anyways let's uh let's keep going
go deeper into the secret world of
assassins and criminals
that lurks just under the surface to
discover that it's pretty boring
and barely makes sense featuring
their own silly cryptocurrencies this
coin it does not represent the monetary
value
it represents the commerce of
relationships you hand me your ticket
i will tear it for a man to grant a
market to another
is slowed extreme amounts of table
matters
the ticket does not stand above the
table the high table wants your life
i had to follow the rules of the table
the eye table the high table high
table under the table under the table
under the table
end of the table under the table serving
the table
everything is under the table and the
same kind of rules you make up playing
freeze tag at recess
you can't kill me but this whole
parallel society of killers and
criminals
manages to stay underground thanks to
the continued silence of
everyone in new york now
can you even say they're part of the
underworld seems like it's just the
world at this point
i mean even the homeless or a highly
trained network of super spies
yeah that was positive it's uh
look this is probably the world the
fictional world i would least want to
live in
because i feel like the implications of
this are horrifying
that everybody is either a criminal
in the criminal services industry the
underground criminal services industry
or uh part of the homeless super spy
network
or um or a target i guess
that that's it and like they are they
must have so many murders going on that
that could explain i thought it was just
because it was new york but that could
explain why nobody reacts
very much to all the like fights and
dead bodies in the middle of them
i guess it's sort of new york anyways
but yeah underground is doing a lot of
work with that word because it's very
overground
um it's happening literally everywhere
all the time
i don't i i might actually because at
first i was
where you are where i was like i guess
this is just like there's so many
criminals that it's just criminalities
everywhere i'm at the point now where i
don't think there are any just like marx
i think
everybody who is the victim of crime was
already doing a different crime and it's
just
criminals doing crime on each other at
this point i don't know if there even
our innocence in this new york i think
it's like
all the people in the background who are
like shocked by the killing it's like
well they're money laundering or
something they're just not involved in
this crime
they're on their way home from a
different robbery entirely yeah with
that many assassins you eventually run
out of targets and you just
turn on each other like it's just
assassins all the way down
i don't think anybody just like works at
a bodega and john wick i think you work
in a bodega but that's your that's your
front you kill people with a hookah
like you have there is right an attack
cat one of those like
bears full of honey that nobody's bought
like turns and then a wall opens and
then it's just like guns everywhere like
everybody yeah explosive chopped cheese
sandwiches um
yeah yeah i uh and i thought that this
to me
i get a little bored with uh uh with the
world building
in this franchise i don't really care
because mostly it's like about an
org chart and who's on top of who and
who's whose rules
uh uh in which jurisdictions count i
feel like there's maybe a better way to
like dramatize this instead of just
having all these sit-downs where they
talk about you know
who uh a code of conduct
matters in this province of the assassin
world i kind of don't care
i i just think it's it's hard at this
point in 2021 to write
tough guy crime boss style and i speak
for personal experience
and like it's just you get money playing
where it's just like we've written every
formulation of like
i'm a tough guy and i'm in charge god
damn it you know like it's how many
times
so what what i think derek colstads of
very brilliantly innovated in this movie
is well if i make up a really
complicated fantasy world
i could just have the tough mob guys
talk about that instead of just like
creative ways to talk about what they're
gonna do to each other which is like
every other movie
uh and so i you know i i really like
that like
i i don't know i think they do a very
good job of like it's it's alternate
reality so you're always learning
something new from the
boring monologuing that would usually
just be like the filler part of the
action movie until they shoot each other
yeah yeah well said all right
keep going no one can get between john
wick and his mission
but that won't stop an army of dumb
schmucks from trying
well just because it's john wick it's
like i knew this was going to happen
saturday night of ethnic stereotypes
guys who literally bring a knife to a
gunfight and his fellow super assassins
who without exception
approached john wick from the front out
in the open for a little chit chat
before the fight
it's good to have you back you working
yeah you sure this is what you want to
do 14 million it's a lot of money
look i'm not a trained killer or
anything but just a thought don't
yeah so again you know i'm not an
assassin
but i feel like one of the first things
they teach you
in assassin school is like don't
announce yourself and have a
conversation with your target
before you attack them that's pretty
much
chapter one book of assassinations don't
let them know you're coming
and if they do find out like don't stand
around and have a little tet
uh uh about uh you know working together
before you pull out your knife and start
shooting
you have to tell them what a stan you
are you got to pay your respects
you're not a wikian or whatever what
what's the barb version of a wick guy
you know how are they going to know that
you're not a wiki and if you don't tell
them how much you love his work
oh no i'm a wit wikian i'm sorry i
yeah i don't know i think that you could
you could have them leap from the
shadows and john wick like barely
escapes and then they have like the
standoff and then they talk
just a thought just a thought ah it is
weird i'll give you there's very
like it's a constantly moving target the
like code of
professional conduct in the wick verse
like it's okay to attack a guy like
seven on one when he's like bleeding out
and unarmed and you've all got machine
guns
but it's like you you you also have to
like shake their hand
first and there's like a there's like a
formalized greeting and stuff like well
but
you're it's totally unfair like why
there's no code of honor here
you're going to try to murder him anime
rules of fighting right now it's like
you've got to have it
with that book we must like you know
queensberry rules oh okay
this isn't even my final form horse
attack yeah
i wrote it in the noses it's like
there's a lot of like truly it is an
honor to meet you on the noble field of
battle mr wick
and now i will shoot you in the face
with a bazooka even though
you have a pencil that's not yeah
all right keep going franchise that
loves guns so much
you'll swear they're compensating for
something i need something
robust robust anything for the
end of the night something big bold
that feels like it hates humanity about
as much as it loves animals
but as long as people are willing to pay
to watch keanu put his health and safety
on the line for our entertainment
they'll keep ending these things with
unapologetic sequel bait
even if he literally has to be wheeled
into his next fight
who's got more left in the tank keanu or
cruz my money's on tom
little guy freaks me out
yeah i think we'll still be getting
mission impossible movies for longer
than we'll be getting john wick movies
they've kind of sort of hinted around
that these two
are gonna be the grand finale i felt
like for wick or miss
or mission problem it should be possible
like mcq is doing two more with cruz and
then
who knows if they'll keep to it but i
feel like they've been making it sound
like this is the
big finish you know okay we're bringing
everybody back
and but again if they do
enough business and it works well enough
who's to say they won't be like ah we'll
do two more
i think they'll do one more wick and
then find ways to spin it off because
well they're doing
there's they're doing another
they're also doing the tv show yeah yeah
yeah and aren't they doing one based on
like the
ballerina academy or whatever i think
that's still in the
in the maybe pile but it's out there
it's it's it's in the ether it may
happen
um and going back to uh uh the the how
they end with sql bait and stuff like
that like
this is one of those franchises like
back to the future where
if you actually run the chronology this
everything marty mcfly goes through in
three movies takes place over 10 days or
something like that
yeah and like this man john wick's
having a bad week
i do i like how they'll occasionally
remind you of that in context like
somebody would be like
oh right i heard about that thing last
week with the dog like
they're at least trying to be like not
that much time is pass gang
yeah let the guy take a nap or something
he doesn't yeah
the the the potty has got to be a
concern there are some times where he
did he's not getting
time for bathroom breaks no no he didn't
um
but he probably couldn't see himself in
the desert
there he's got a he's got a few moments
but i hope they give him some time to
relax
and uh yeah i guess lawrence fishburne's
fine he just has a few light scarves on
his face after getting
cut eight times seven times with uh it's
just a samurai sword
strong strong face uh all right this is
a whole debate
should we bring people in on our our
behind-the-scenes debate do we think
the the bowery king did he build
this network from previously existing
homeless people like
did he gather together homeless people
were like we should become a network of
spies and criminals and assassins all
around the city
or are these trained assassins that he's
then been like
you guys should dress as hobos and
scatter yourselves around the city
and pretend to be you know drifters as
my eyes and ears
to me this is like an internship or an
entry-level position in the world of
assassin's creed
you can't go straight into the gucci
turtlenecks and
you know having a cool uh gimmick and
stuff like that like you gotta put on
the big coat and the sweatpants and sit
in the subway for a few years
you know get your get your legs under
you and then you get to graduate to
maybe like
uh you know a guy who runs a donut shop
that's
actually like a a a cyanide
vendor or something like that you have
to say like oh what glazed doughnut is
it today
oh strawberry glaze is delicious i think
the continental series should be
every season he like moves one rung up
the criminality
ladder so yeah by season 10 they're an
elite assassin
but the first few seasons is just like
donut shop covering for a place to buy
grenades
i want to see the class where you learn
the innuendos that's what i want to say
it's a huge uh translation of dictionary
book like
i hope peter serafinowicz is running
that school he's the best at it yeah he
was okay
um yeah no so i think uh barry is a
is rung one on the ladder and then you
you move your way up is my assumption
but i'm sure we'll learn more
anyways keep going starring
the wicker man never sneak up on a man
who's been in a chemical fire
i just saw hot rod for the first time uh
this uh
like a couple weeks ago and uh man
that's probably my favorite ian mcshane
performance now
maybe it's just so memorable i've never
seen him like that before i believe
you've never seen hot rod
i know it slipped through the cracks uh
you'd think that i'd catch it but
it's an underrated gem oh so good yeah
yeah uh nothing but good things to say
about
hot rod and ian mcshane's performance so
if if like me you haven't seen it
uh let this honest trailer be the be the
final push one thing away from today's
honest trailer commentaries let it be
watch hot rod yep there you go anyhow
keep going
ruby rose oh we're using our poor names
then i
am dax slamhammer orpheus you see rats
with wings
but i see the internet i used to love
him
siree national basketball assassination
dog woman a little cuisine
also starring head shots like the
regretful headshot
the almost forgot headshot the spinning
headshot
there are even more headshots than we
took here waiting for the back head
shots
i was amazed
the halle berry
the put him out of his misery had shot
now you see me headshot the grab and go
headshot
the class wikipedia
the throat slash plus headshot combo
platter
the dazed and confused they
ain't anywhere near the headshot
the mercy kill headshot
the chin shot the wild west
you know what we're missing is though
when he's on the sumo and he's shooting
down into like
who was in my list the exploder we had
to cut some
i think i called it the the death kuma
explorer
chunky style and
who even needs a good headshot
that was a great we we cheered in the
theater john wick chapter two
and john wick three lorem ipsum
uh pause there's a one thing we forgot
to mention in the trailer
that uh i think we've we've remarked
upon is like
the over abundance of
um like rooms with halls of mirror hall
of mirrors in this
in this world and like assassin friendly
locations like oh we just rolled into
this uh
uh collection of knives and and
six-shooter stories
literally everywhere he goes is like
underground
neon euro trash nightclub that's all
hallway
like that's every place that he enters
again it's a fantasy world places that
are just open air
as well you know like not everything is
like a dank cavernous like
we're underneath prague and it's 3 a.m
now you need the dank you need the day
you need the bank
yeah every location is is yeah we i
think it was the
the us trailer where we talked about how
like
movies too many halls of mirrors movies
have like a hundred times more
halls of mirrors than kissing booths
kissing boobs and halls of mirrors are
only a thing that exists in
in that john mulaney bit about quicksand
it's like if you
if you based it on movies you'd be
encountering halls of mirrors in your
life
all the time yeah like it never happens
all right keep going okay is every
killer for hire new york on the same
group text
unsubscribe yeah a lot of group texts um
and also uh something else about the
name you'd be like oh crap
yeah right yeah the the the ladies who
work in like the steno pool
underneath the continental like that are
they like also a roller derby team or is
it like oh
you're you work here for life here's
your sailor jerry tattoos
get an old-fashioned typewriter yeah and
i guess you graduate you become the like
the
uh madame of a burlesque troop i guess
that's the only way
you can go it's like reverse disneyland
you have to have a ton of tattoos on
your hands or they're like no not
interested get it
right we're trying to create an
atmosphere here yeah that's just the
the portland branch of the assassination
world
i didn't notice until this most recent
type did you that the guy who plays the
penguin whose name i'm playing gun from
gotham is in there
in uh i believe it's two hmm okay i
didn't even notice that
he's got the two through yeah yeah he's
got the lips the lip ring
all right well uh thank y'all for
watching we still have more show
so stick around uh uh and but if you
haven't yet subscribe
like hit that bell um later today we're
gonna tell you what to watch
after you finish the falcon and the
winter soldier in another video
because that's all wrapped up so uh give
that a watch as well
uh and also we have things we cut from
this
fairy trailer let's see what didn't make
it in
in the wikiverse you're either an
assassin a fancy shopkeeper or a murder
hobo
take your pick
starring i'd rather die than live in a
world where i can't kick your ass
broke ass morpheus i can only show you
the door
you're the one that has to shoot through
it you see rats with wings
but i see the internet chairman killer
jane wig
the wick and the dead
uh yeah there you go um what was i gonna
say oh mark mark de costco
how do you say his name yeah uh yeah all
of those were references to the fact
that
uh he was the host of iron chef america
which is one of my
one of my favorite shows he was the
chairman and they say he's the
cousin or or like the nephew of the
japanese chairman kaga i don't think
that's true but i like the mythology i
like
it no he's not he's not really related
to that actor
their characters in the iron chef verse
are related
okay just checking i think that goes
without saying wait are you saying that
that
chairman kaga in iron chef japan is not
a real uh
eccentric um food uh stadium builder
that's
he's just an actor no he's he's real
spencer it's just
good the original iron chef is based on
a true story i think as we all know
okay okay obviously
all right all right all right good um
okay
lord taylor by the way is that actor's
name he plays the penguin on gotham
well there you go um so uh
now on to the questions that you've been
putting into the chat
um adam halbert writes is lon the
closest to an actual wick because he has
a beard and a dog
yeah i mean look moonlight as an
assassin i hate to even put this out
into the universe but if someone were
to harm taco i feel like that would
make any of us snap but you especially
and you would you would be fully
justified in whatever you did to that
person afterwards
i i i just generally feel like it would
be
cool if a guy like me went on a crazy
streak of
like a 42 year old like nerd world
writer
guy like i would be one of those people
you would not suspect to go on like
you would never suspect it but you do
have a past
style one where like you actually don't
have any idea what you're doing i guess
that's blue ruin basically
yeah we all know if i was in the wick
first though i'd just be like
next to jason mansoukas we're like talk
mr wick
you're powering yeah you'd be in the bat
with the barry boys
one of those guys in the bowery like i
don't know man
under the table uh okay
interesting a lot of interesting
questions um uh
uh kelly w says is more of a comment the
director said the gold coins are more
like
business cards it's like a business card
that you use to pay for drinks and
services
well it's like you know if you ever go
as someone i used to be a paralegal as
i've talked about you go to like some
bars and you put your business card in
the bowl
and then when you do that they might
pick it out and you get a week like a
night full of free drinks so that's kind
of like that like you switch those off
i mean but like on some level it has to
function as currency like he goes into
the doctor and is like
show me up here's a coin like that guy
can't go give john wick's business card
to someone else's
payment for something it's it's it's
gotta on some level work as money right
or what's the point
yeah uh let's see so
uh benjamin abramowitz uh uh suggests
can we hide a brad pitt run over scene
in every honest trailer from now on like
the allen raptor
i don't think he can really hide that
kevin's very talented as an editor but i
don't think you can
subtly sneak that into the breath and be
flung around
in the background i like where your
head's at um
think big uh okay mj pretzer ass uh
question for all they've said they will
keep making these movies until the
public no longer wants them
what kills this franchise
i mean i i do think sort of what we were
saying before like there will be a point
where keanu will just like
get too long in the tooth or not want to
do it anymore
it'll just stop seeming believable
on screen or acceptable for us and i
feel like that'll do it i don't feel
like you could replace
keanu as wick i think you could you
could bring you could do like the halle
berry spin-off or the continental
spin-off or whatever
but i think on some you can't replace
john wick but that's what breaks it is
that like we find out that john wick had
a daughter and she can also kill people
with library books
oh no and there's there's like there's
definitely a
prequel-shaped hole in this franchise uh
because they keep talking
i'm pretty sure we haven't seen it or
even described it like the impossible
task john wick did to leave the life
like what was the impossible thing he
did when he was younger um
slightly younger uh but an interesting
fact from adam alan preslend
uh all stunt men grow beards and then
shave parts off so they can use them
again for other scenes
so every stuntman you know starts with a
beard and then
as necessary can can move that around
it's stunt beard classic stunt beard
classic stuff i mean that's that's what
this is yeah
that's interesting um this one's kind of
tough
might require a little bit of thought
but it's an interesting question um
slaviton rock right
are there any other relatively small
movies with great premises where you
want to see the john wick sequel
approach and explore the world and just
get more of that
place you were living in oh
um hack danielle i i mean
i've always wanted to see more of the
world of the last dragon apparently
there's a bunch of different gangs
fighting around new york
all ran by different guys who run
arcades i want to see that
you could certainly do uh jumping up
that the warriors
if you wanted to just have more burrows
or or update that and the
the gangs have changed or something like
that like what are the baseball fury's
uh doing now
uh i i mean i'm tempted to just say
because i loved it so much in the little
weird world that created game night that
comedy
oh years ago like i definitely think
because we just see
the sort of like one little thing
happening but it's such a weird cartoony
alternate universe just more generally
uh and i just want to see more jesse
plemons
yeah so yeah i would i would love that i
feel like you could do something like
that with the game night first you could
do a
john he even has the little dog he could
totally do it john wick movie
yeah wow yeah in game night
doing john wick i'm in i love it uh and
then we'll we'll close with this and
it's more of just a pat on the back for
uh our lovely parent company fandom lady
uh senbon zakura
writes the fandom wiki for the john wick
franchise is called the john wicky and i
think that's amazing
i agree well done 100 agree i love it
like uh
like the star wars one is wikipedia um
and uh so yeah any other wiki title
names you can think of uh
i'm a big pun fan so and i i love uh
john bailey uh
suggested john wikipedia which i think
was the standout uh
the headshot name of the uh of the
montage so
uh it takes a village here um but we'll
be back
very collaborative yes we'll be back
next week um
for another thing that uh
let's see um how to tease this
uh well it's another uh continuation
of somebody's story um
it it it will it's not a sequel but
it'll probably lead to sequels
of someone you've heard of before
that's all i'm gonna say uh thank you
lon thank you danielle
thanks everyone for joining this episode
of honest trailer commentaries we'll see
you next week bye
[Music]
you